what's up guys this is jung from geek
culture and today we're at portmart
funan and if you don't know what that is
well stick around because we have a
bunch of cool toys to show you guys so
let's get started shall we
[Music]
pokemon is basically a toy store that
has built its name in the toy industry
with this insane collaboration and
amount of collectibles what they do is
they basically specialize in all these
realistic and cute figurines that are
sold in toy blind boxes
and if you haven't seen they have set up
a crazy amount of displays right here
for us at popmart funan so today we're
going to be checking out what they have
for us install and perhaps unbox a few
ourselves so if you like garcias and
toys this is the place for you
inside the store you'll see columns and
columns of amazing toys and you'll take
note that there will be a bunch of
well-known ips like disney my little
pony to harry potter and even naruto
that's pretty insane and one thing you
gotta know is that once these collected
editions are sold out for example the
demo zodiac here
these are probably the last four boxes
so if they are gone they are gone so you
gotta get them while it's hot
[Applause]
[Music]
portmart also supports a lot of local
toy designers like wet works and gaga
tree which you can check out all their
entire collections on this particular
shelf
some of these guys are hand painted like
the ones by daniel e here they are
highly valued collectibles and guess
what not all of them are for sale
some of these toys like the ap 2k by
singaporean designer wetworks can be
purchased at a slightly more premium
price tag but that's only because of its
even more limited quantity size and
design
going back to popnut next all their
collaborations you can see here they
have a bunch of mainstream ips from
hello kitty to sesame street fudetama
mickey disney toy story minions you name
it have it all not only do promote sell
figurines but if you are looking for
pins accessories or even plushies like
this you can check out the section over
here and then this section over here
where you have a lot more choices in
plushies and if you're not a fan of the
gacha experience you can get the entire
box here to make sure you have all the
collections and perhaps increase your
chances of getting the hidden edition
figurine
[Music]
[Music]
this wraps up the entire video we hope
you guys enjoyed everything so far feel
free to drop by popmart at funan to
check out all these awesome collectibles
and collaborations and if you haven't
already do consider subscribing to our
channel and smash that bell icon if you
want to be notified of any future videos
this is chung from geek culture signing
out
[Music]
you